le visage de george floyd plane sur la
ville de minneapolis le tribunal de la
capitale du minnesota accueille l'un des
procès les plus médiatiques de ces
dernières années aux états unis une
procédure ralenti par l'extrême
sensibilité que revêt la faire aucun
choix n'est laissé au hasard
et sûrement pas celui des 15 jurés une
centaine de citoyens américains à
d'abord été tirés au sort avant d'être
soumis à des interrogatoires poussés la
défense comme l'accusation ayant droit
de veto si un des membres du jury leur
semble trop impliqué personnellement
politiquement ou émotionnellement dans
l' affaire qui a secoué le pays
sur ces images le procureur questionne
un juré potentiel dont l'anonymat est
conservé vous êtes en total désaccord
avec le concept de démantèlement de la
police de minneapolis unis juste chien
pouvez-vous juste me donner un peu de
votre opinion sur ce concept ce qu'il
représente pour vous et pourquoi vous y
est opposée oui et bien comme je les dis
plutôt je pense que vous savez il s'agit
de fournir un service utile à notre
société et donc je ne suis pas d'accord
avec le démantèlement
concernant la procédure elle va voir se
poser deux argumentations déjà esquissé
pendant les auditions des jurés
potentiels
l'accusation soutient que derek chauvine
intentionnellement fait un usage
excessif de la force par ailleurs un
troisième chef d'inculpation a été
ajoutée à l'encontre du policier meurtre
au troisième degré plus facile à
démontrer car la notion d'intention
n'apparaît plus compliquant encore
davantage l'argumentation de la défense
une défense qui devrait s'articuler
autour des causes de la mort de georges
flood
l'un des arguments avancés étant que
l'homme est mort d'une overdose au
fontanil à l'extérieur du tribunal
quelques manifestants et une sécurité
renforcée
la crainte des autorités c'est de voir
se reproduire ces scènes qui avait suivi
la diffusion des images de la mort de
georges tron
des émeutes qui s'était répandue dans
plusieurs grandes villes américaines au
printemps dernier faisant ressurgir les
fractures de la société américaine la
fed georges floyd est devenu hautement
symbolique le sort de derek chauvine
sera scruté dans le monde entier
de quoi ajouter encore un peu plus de
pression pour ce procès définitivement
exceptionnel